Pichette Simon and sous-chef James have
made their mark by breaking all the
rules
7-up local ingredients with a quirky
twist for our starters we've ordered
black pudding with bacon pepper mackerel
with horseradish snow and it's a martyr
consomme with a flower pot full of
tapanade for soil and pea shoes very
hard to read the soup navigate your way
around things like this I smashed
private the shack ok is head good it's
just gimmick isn't it how much I mean I
know that's the soil but bloody hell J
my soil blessing more and this is all
they need to know less is more
their key as mustard I mean really key
but far too ambitious for their good
the minute you start trying to become
too clever Europe for intense scrutiny
how can I like that effect it mean cause
effect for our mains
we've got more conventional
salmon wrapped in a herb crust
vegetarian cannelloni and bavette of
beef I mean they're attractive looking
dishes I mean I like the presentation I
actually think this is a really well
sourced me well cooked well handled if I
had any criticism it would be the red
wine jus because it's really sweet it's
almost the consistency of being right
being ugh it's actually very nice much
more delicious yeah but they just need
to rein it back in finally it's time for
pudding
a tree of strawberry desserts Bakewell
tart sellers nice let's do it and a
great local cheese board see that and
that fits this thing here looks like
it's out at Paris Hilton's bathroom it
doesn't make sense
brilliant then looks delicious and it
tastes delicious
Eric ice cream what else this was
clearly the best second time this one
yeah that's actually nice
time to call the team together for a
debrief if I just say that was delicious
really good unfortunate didn't start
like that
if there's one strong message you're
trying to bloody heart I've tasted the
greatness and tonight has been a
disappointment stick to what you're good
at doing yeah and for me to think of any
good restaurant is how every other table
has been looked after and tonight
there's no second surprise
we've actually got Angelus sister having
dinner as well I didn't really like the
bread I thought the bread was a bit
heavy and I liked the tomato thing I
have to say I love all that and what was
your starter James I had the black
pudding
it was quite sticky and quite quite
heavy so don't worry about trying to be
too different when you're good at what
you do get back to what you're good at
doing and stick to that